can you believe that the Honda
dealership just quoted $400 to make
another key fob and it's going to take
an hour or two sitting in the waiting
room but first I want to show you how
you can save hundreds of dollars with
Tom's key company today I'm going to
show you how easy it is to make a spare
key for this Honda Odyssey stick around
to the end I'm going to call the car
dealership and ask them how much it
would cost if I drove in and had them
make a key fob okay we're going to pair
my key fire up the
app and it tells me I got to plug this
in the OBD Port plug this guy in we got
to look around near the gas and brake
pedal and plug it
in to make your life a little bit easier
pick up this optional extension
cable so we can see what's going on with
programmer doing Bluetooth scan and it
found the matching serial number make
the Bluetooth connection we should see
this Comm light current turn on there we
go Bluetooth connection has been made
okay let's
continue now it's important to note you
want to have all existing working keys
are present as well as any new keys the
pla pair program this new one the new
one we're programming today is an
aftermarket key no Honda Logo should
still work just great we've got one
working key with the tile key finder so
you can always find your key and this is
the new key we're going to program our
working key locks and like locks the
doors new one does nothing and our
existing working key starts the engine
just great and of course this one does
not
scan the
VIN I'll warn you the VIN scan tool is
not ideal you may want to look at your
uh vehicle registration certificate your
insurance card or uh the VIN sticker on
the side of your vehicle okay let's go
ahead and
submit and it successfully populated
we've got a 2019 Honda Odyssey and will
note under endin manually you can also
uh proceed past that and manually select
your eake model okay so we'll
continue all right which kind of key is
this this is a smart key meaning a push
button start vehicle so we'll enter the
smart key programming system it has some
important notes it shouldn't take more
than 15 minutes uh stay in the app make
sure you've got all your previously
programmed Keys as well as any new ones
and be sure you've got a strong cellular
or Wi-Fi signal there's a text port
phone number you can contact and get
some assistance all right let's start
programming okay initiating
programming got to let it do some
downloads be back as soon as this
thing's up to 100% it's really important
for you to know you must have at least
one working key to use Tom's key
company's do-it-yourself solutions to
make a spare and if you've lost all your
keys we can point you to someone local
that can help you get a key for your
vehicle again okay we're almost up to
100% here we
go all right preparing the dongle
getting ready please wait notice my com
light turned off should turn back on
there it's back
on okay leave the ignition the off
position turn the hazard lights on and
let's go ahead and hit
continue during the this procedure it's
best not to have extra cell phones Wi-Fi
or Bluetooth devices inside the vehicle
that's important warning for us
here click the start button two times to
turn on the on position so one two I did
not start the
engine we'll see that came
up and the logo is fired up so the
vehicle is not
running all
right
continue take all keyless remotes
outside the vehicle at least 10 ft okay
I'm taking the new one and the other one
outside the
vehicle I know it's far enough away cuz
the vehicle's detecting that there's no
key in the vehicle
currently okay let's go ahead and
continue now bring only the currently
programmed working remote inside the
vehicle place it next to the gear
shifter this vehicle this is my gear
shifter
there okay let's continue detecting the
key see some red lights coming on down
there now tells me to take the keyless
remote outside the vehicle
all
right back to the warning air on the
dash there's no keys in the vehicle okay
keys outside the
vehicle please right now bring the new
remote back inside hold the backs side
of the remote over the face of the
vehicle start button so this is a little
different keep your phone at least 2 ft
away pushing the backside the new
keyless remote next to start button
keeping my phone a couple feet away
let's hit continue
please
wait in less than 15 seconds click the
start button twice with the back of the
remote one two okay I've clicked it
twice says please wait on the dashboard
I see it's in accessory
mode I've seen this spinning weight
signal before it usually means the app
is
frozen so this is a little problem
all right no they're not working
properly yes I want to contact teex
support okay it gives me a phone number
to call technical support can be really
helpful in solving problems so it's nice
to do this when they're available it
turned out the app just froze before
telling me programming was successful
watch what happens when I test the key
okay the engine starts so that's good we
got both keys in the
vehicle let's see if these both lock and
unlock the door well that one works
let's try the new one H look at that the
new one works as
well okay I'm going to unplug the dongle
we're going to give this a test let's
try our keys here's our existing
one unlocks and locks the door here's a
new
one unlocks and locks the door
beautiful let's set both keys outside
the vehicle and bring them back in one
at a time to test that they start the
engine first I'm going to check I've got
them far enough away nothing
happens back one
key got one key in the vehicle
now fires up the engine just
beautifully
okay going take this key out let's get
the other
one and here's a new key Moment of
Truth boom look at that we've got two
working Keys wasn't that easy with the
help of Tom's key company to make a
spare key one little note you may know
that different keys can be programmed
for driver 1 driver two that kind of
thing it adjusts the location of your
seed and other things you may need to
follow the instructions in your owner's
manual to reprogram the driver 1 and
Driver 2 key to return to your
particular settings Vehicles Toms key
company can help you make spare keys and
fobs for thousands and thousands of
vehicles without leaving home be sure
you include our optional Key by photo
key cutting service all you got to do is
snap three photos from directly above
the key recommend you turned over get a
couple different
angles and that way we can cut your new
keyblade so it arrives already fitting
vehicle if your battery ever dies you
can still get in your car isn't that
amazing I'm going to call the Honda
dealership and find out how much they're
going to charge to make a spare key fob
for this
vehicle good afternoon Monda service I
can I help you hi I'm trying to find out
how much it cost to get another key fob
for a Honda Odyssey push to
start okay the push to start Keys uh
including the price of the key so plus
programming I believe they start at
around 4 00 plus taxes about 400 plus
tax is 400 pretty good quote or like I
might get in there be 450 or something
it depends kind of the one set price
that I know of is the labor for the
programming which is 200 okay plus
whatever the cost of the key is there
are several keys so it all depends on
the customer okay super thank you so
much can you believe that the Honda
dealership just quoted $400 to make
another key fob and it's going to take
an hour or two sitting in the waiting
room get any easier than that come to
Tom's ke.com where you can order your
spare keys and programming equipment
it'll ship right to your door you'll
have spare keys in about 15 minutes and
save hundreds of dollars in the process
if you run into problems while you're
making your spare key no worries reach
out to us help atomsk key.com we aim to
provide exceptional customer service and
we'll help solve your problem and if for
whatever reason we can't get the problem
solved and your spare key just won't
work send it all back to us you get a
full refund it's that easy if you've
lost all your keys I'm sorry about that
go check out our all keys lost section
where we'll point you to a company that
can come to you and help you make a
spare be sure you smash the like button
and subscribe so you can find this video
again to follow along as you make your
spare key it also lets YouTube know that
people are interested in saving money on
spare keys so this video gets shared
with other people I'm Mike with tomsky
company please visit tomy.com and place
your order today